can you go over the differences between
enabling somebody
and helping somebody hmm that's a good
short insightful question there what do
you think dave
well i think you have the uh phd in
counseling
but um i've got an opinion of course
i've got an opinion about everything
i do too i think enabling somebody is
for you and helping them
is for them enabling somebody um
paying somebody's rent makes you feel
good versus
i'm trying to help somebody out of a
spot that's going to actually
benefit them in the long run that's how
that's just off top of my head what do
you think
i think most enablers would think would
have a hard time
realizing they're doing it for
themselves right so
um you know you're doing it for you well
i'm not doing this for me i'm doing it
to help him
and um so you know the thing i always
think about when enabling
is the classic giving a drunk a drink
are you participating in
their misbehavior causing it so you look
at it on the back end
causing it to continue are you are you
are you like joining up for crazy
um and uh if you're participating in
their misbehavior
then you're a helicopter mom coming in
the kids misbehaving and you're bailing
them you know
you're saying well the teacher's wrong
you know versus my house where i grew up
the teacher was never wrong even when
they were wrong never right
even if the teacher was a toxic abuser
they were on my parents team
you know it was like um so you know
there's just no chance that you could
have a helicopter parent coming out of
my house
so uh which is good i mean but
versus and so when you're enabling you
really are not helping and if you'll
stop and realize that then it'll help
you not be an enabler
right and when i have been when i have
been in a situation and i'll tell you
the other thing is there's something
about enabling
i think it's harder to help
and requires more effort emotional
energy and time
than it does to enable more
intentionality right it's kind of like
the guy standing on the side of the road
i will you know we'll work for food okay
it's hard to put the guy in the car
and take him and have him cut grass
and then pay right uh then it is just
give him some money right
and if you just give him some money
you're probably really
you know participating in something that
that is not helpful mm-hmm
whereas if you take him out and teach
him skill yeah or if he really just
needs food take him over the restaurant
buying a plate of food
right um and of course you know we all
know the story sometimes you find out
that when what they're after anyway
they're just
they're just running they're just
running that corner that's their corner
but
uh aside from that are you really
helping
and it's almost a cheap you're cheap out
when you're enabling it's easier it's
quicker
i'll just throw some money at it right
out of mind yeah i'll just throw some
whatever at it so
if you are participating in things that
at the end of the story have caused them
harm
which you kind of got to pan back and do
that and it
you know you sit down with somebody they
come to you and they say you know i need
i need i need money for rent why um
and you dig into it you realize i got a
drug problem so when you pay the rent
basically you bought the drugs
right right so you've got it it's harder
to take that person by the hand lead
them
into a 12-step group you know go pay for
their counseling
right or their coaching or whatever they
need to pay for the rehab it's harder
to do that and i'm assuming all things
are equal with the money you know but
but
you know it just takes more effort and
and you know i found this also to be
true about giving
just your generosity it takes more
effort to do
giving right that's right that's going
to actually have a
demonstrable effect help people in the
long term
and not just be a sieve right yeah so
these aren't real that's
none of that's a real good um
clinical definition or even not even a
clear definition but it's just
observation yeah
and i think you and i are coming at it
just ones on the front ones on the back
is like what's this money that what's
this money what's this
opportunity what's this what's this
thing you're you're giving somebody
what's how's it what's the fruit gonna
be after you plant the tree and
i like to look up front if somebody asks
me for money
um okay let me give an example how does
this play into your definition okay um
my friend who mishandles money and
that's their only sin
right they're just disorganized
impulsive immature right
and they call up and go you know
i need two hundred i said no
i you know if i say yeah here's 200
right i'm an enabler
there you go okay if i don't and i say
listen i'll give you 200 but only if
you're enrolled in financial peace
university
only after i look at your budget with
you and only after you agree to stop
these behaviors
that are causing you to be broke in the
first place right
one's an enabler one's a helper same
amount of money
and i i don't know how to describe the
difference in those two i i would
and if i just gave him the 200 how's
that about me
because you can it's dismissive it gets
you out of it you don't have to have the
hard conversation of saying no i don't
want it to be emotionally lazy
right or it feels good to somebody comes
to me because i've taken care of my
business
the way you describe that i think you
can you got to be careful because it can
be judgmental
which is somebody ask you for 200 i'm
going to read into
why you need it what you haven't done
and what you're probably going to do
with it versus
hey man i'll just help you out yeah and
sometimes i
i will go too far down the road and
saying oh you don't have 200
because of this because of this because
of this sometimes you just need 200
bucks but i i think
what you mentioned coming up front is
i'm gonna sit down have a hard
conversation with you before i just
give money to you yeah i don't
understand drive-by that's exactly right
and that all comes back to
intentionality and that's that is real
love
right is actually caring enough about
them to
not not necessarily be judgmental and
confront every issue but just start
asking a bunch of questions
why are you here and then you're
starting to ascertain
am i really helping or am i funding
crazy that's exactly right because with
enabling you're almost
always funding some kind of crazy some
kind of dysfunction
some kind of misbehavior some kind of
toxic
uh the kid misbehaving the helicopter
mom is you're funding it
right then and sometimes people getting
a bind and they just need some help
yeah and i don't mind doing that that's
exactly right but
i think you you you i mean we we're
we're saying it over and over but
man just be intentional and get involved
yeah
ask that extra question hey what what
happened you doing okay
is there a bigger thing i can be
supportive of what else what else is
going on in your world that uh the 28
year old that lives in his mother's
basement and games all day long and
won't get a job
right mom mom is an enabler an
absolute enabler and so because she's
participating
in allowing him to not become who god
designed him to be
and that how that helps her is she has
to keep her baby around
she gets to not have a hard conversation
she gets to not do the hard
parent job of constructing boundaries
and holding them up holding them firm
right
and so this whole thing just protects
her her fantasy world and she just keeps
perpetuating down this down the street
i have never thought about it until
today
in this way that enabling is emotionally
lazy you you're character lazy it's just
not investment in other people you're
not willing to
you know to do the do the stuff that's
good for them and so you just
you throw something you know you you you
just allow it
or even ask the the that next question
and the next question how are you
it's just it's it's i see it's
emotionally lazy it's character lazy
it's
it's spiritually lazy it's yeah it just
treats a person as a transaction instead
of a relationship
yeah it's not really loving no
absolutely not at the end of the day
it's just because you didn't love them
enough to help them
to truly get into what's going on in
your heart yeah you know 28-year-old
lives in your basement
and and they they have absolutely no
ambition and you still do their
you still make their clothes failure to
launch movie you know that kind of stuff
you still watch their clothes you still
cook their meals you they don't pay
anything
they they basically are operating
emotionally at a 14 year old level
and they're a full-time gamer down there
um you know i mean it's just
that that's you know what you have done
is you have stunted the emotional growth
of your kid
right uh by allowing this
and so my friends know when they call me
for help
there's i'm gonna be the first in line
yeah but they also know
they're gonna get a whole bunch of
questions how are you doing okay what's
going on
your kids okay why are we here yeah how
are we not gonna be here again
i love you yeah yeah yeah yeah if if i'm
gonna help you
i don't want you to have to be here
again because otherwise i was an enabler
there you go
wow that's a good question i like that